hello everyone and welcome back to the
world Fisher random championship it's
the finals with Lassalle vs. Magnus
cross and this is Game three of the
classical time section or as they're
calling it the slow rapid so after they
won first game was a draw and then
Westwood One a very nice second game a
brilliant opening a brilliant attack and
then a brilliant finishing to the game
so now across and has a chance to get
back at him it's really important at the
score as many points as possible in the
classical portion of the of the match as
the a win in the classical time section
is worth three points so you want to get
as many points as possible of course so
without further ado let's check out in
the game Wesley with the white pieces
opens with E 4 we have East six d4 d5
and now II five sort of an advanced
variation of the French Fisher random
opening we've c5 pretty much the same
stuff D captures now in the Queen
captures on c5 we have Knight to b3
giving the black Queen away Queen to c7
and now defending d5 pawn with f4 Knight
the b6 and Bishop to e2 now by Wesley
continuing development knife the e7 the
knight can now either come to c6 or to
five depending on what white plays
Knight to f3 in the now Knight to c4 and
excellent square for the knight if white
wants to get rid of it then he will have
to give up the bishop pair we have
Bishop to d3 by Wesley and now comes
Knight the c8 this Knight is now coming
over to b6 dente four and from there the
two nights will be harassing the B to
pawn so a four by Wesley preparing a5
but Magnus gets the knight in just in
time with Nightbeat Knight 8b 6 a
five-night stay for now going after the
B to pawn and here Wesley doesn't like
Roque to sort of an odd place for the
for the rook but after you defend it
it's interesting to see what the Knights
are actually doing there but okay Wesley
goes for Bishop captures on c4 with
Queen captures on c4 Magnus now captures
who the Queen offers a queen trade
Wesley accepts Queen captures D captures
and the Nightbeat a d4 great square for
the knight
also if not I think
for example to b5n 2d6 should be it
should be very good so Bishop to e7 now
controlling d6 with the bishop and here
comes Bishop to h4 Wesley decides to
trade his dark squared bishop that's
basically doing nothing for Carlson's
bishop that controls the very important
d6 square that's the d6 square so Magnus
traits here with bishop characters on h4
Knight captures and now a nice queenside
castle and we have Knight H back to f3
so getting the right back into the game
defending the knight as with castling
the rook was attacking it so look the d5
by Magnus hoping for real characters on
a5 but Wesley quickly gets rid of it
with b3 so what do you do here
Magnus has to decide thus you want to
capture unbe 3 or maybe he wants to go
from Knight to c3 Knight to c4 meter
does look interesting but after the King
moves to be two there doesn't seem to be
a good square for the knight you have to
go back and then perhaps trade on b5 so
Magnus first trades C capture C captures
and just goes back Knights to c5
so with King to c2 now defending the
pawn here now the knight can move and
Bishop to d7 now Magnus has to bring the
other rope into the game as well will be
for pushing crossings Knight back
Knights to a6 attacking the b4 pawn now
and King to b3 so a lot of activity for
Wesley's King and also the C file is now
open to Wesley will deliver check double
play rook see for bringing the other
look over to see one double up rooks on
the C file and be very happy with his
position whereas Crossan still has a
funny night on a6 above 27 not doing all
that much and a ruby that still has to
be developed so rook the d8 Magnus
prefers to keep his King here on the
Queen side to help out with the defense
of the Queen side pawns he doesn't
prefer the castle so rook H the c1 with
check King to be 8 and now rook the C
for preparing rook a c1 to develop on
the C file with Bishop d8 by Magnus now
he has doubled rooks on the D file and
rook a c1 Wesley doubles on the C file
with h6 now taking away the g5 square
from Wesley's night and h4
allowing the magnets to push g5 here and
now b5 by Magnus he says either you
trade here with a cap for some v6 Hassan
or you go back with the rook so Wesley
says first I'm gonna go back with the
rook rook force for - see - and your b5
pawn could become a liability
further down the game with King to b7 by
Magnus and now rook to D - now Wesley
decides to switch the rooks over to the
D file as his two knights are much much
better than Carson's Knight and Bishop
here so if he if he trades rooks then
the end game should be superior for him
we have Knight back to b8 hoping to
bring the knight back into the game and
not rook C to D 1 we have looked the c8
Magnus now as he doesn't want to trade
now he transfers his rooks hopefully to
the C file night Stewie to Wesley now
quickly wants to trade that you cannot
get the other Luke over to the C file as
the c5 square is covered by the pawn so
brush up the c6 and here Knight F to D
for getting the Knights to a very nice
square and then out g5 by Magnus other
than that there are no seemingly good
moves you could you could bring the
route back to d8 but that's just saying
that your rope the c8 idea was wasn't
all that great so here Magnus pushes g5
we have Knight captures and c6 by Wesley
Luke capture Sundy to route captor Sundy
to and now Knight captures on c6 so
Carlson was able to get rid of his you
know a fishy bishop and now he has a
rook and Knight against a rock and the
knight but Wesley definitely has a much
more active position in here Wesley
misses the opportunity for rook to d7
check it's a great trick because you
cannot block you have to move the King
and then Wesley just wins the f7 pawn
because if you block then just rook
capture screen captures and now you grab
this guy here F captures and g5 which
will be which will be very hard for
black to play after h5 it's just very
unlikely that black will be able to stop
this so it's a very interesting that
Wesley misses rook to e7 but he has a
different idea he plays Knight to c3
and goes after b5 and that leaves the
option of this move
so of course on just defense that you
can then for example if a6 the defending
b5 you can just capture here so Magnus
prefers to capture on f4 later he can go
rook to g8 become the g2 point and he
already has a fast f3 pawn but it comes
at a price Knight captures here now the
thread is Knight to d6 check which will
cost Magnus material so King back to be
8 and now rook to d7 grabbing a lot of
activity going for the f7 pawn we have a
6 pushing the knight back and now Knight
to d6 and here Magnus has to decide what
to do whether to capture the e5 pawn or
to maybe play something else capturing
the e5 pawn is the best course of action
for Magnus here as after rugby 7 check
King 8 look to b6 going after the point
now you have looked the c6 you can block
this so after rook rook captures here a
knight characters here Wesley gets the
f7 pawn and then the game continues for
example h5 and Wesley is still better he
has a much more active position but at
least the material is equal so after
Knight to d6 Knight captures on e5 his
best for the best for Magnus but Magnus
decides for Knights to d4 which further
complicates things we've teamed a four
by Wesley and now rook to g8 and here
Magnus was already very low on time well
both of them were very long time Magnus
was lower on time this is move 38 and he
still needs to make two more moves to
reach time control he has about two
minutes on the clock and here he has to
decide what to do well after Luke to g8
it's Wesley's move wesley plays and
Knight captures on f7 a much more
straightforward idea was b5 but b 5
requires a lot of calculation and when
you're low on time you don't have it but
just to show it
b5 threatening of course it just just
imposed upon now Knight captures Knight
captures pawn captures keen captures and
now you just have a 6 a 7 will be very
strong and also you can just pick up
these two guys so after rook captures
and g2 you will play rook captures on f7
and now your position is just just
winning black will not be able to pull
this
as you already have a rope here and
black doesn't really have any good
contra play if if you do nothing then
white is just winning if you go after
some checks then white can just bring
the King over and pick up for example
the e6 pawn and it's just much much
better position for example Roxy to
check King d6 rook checks pick up d6
pawn or or ideas like that but point is
a Wesley is very low on time he doesn't
have time for Takako at b5
he goes for Knight captures on f7 and
now Magnus goes for Knight to f5 and
here we have Knight to d6 by Wesley he
offers the trade of knights
this is move 40 here each time control
he hit seven 17 seconds when he played
it and Magnus now has to make a move his
also below a minute on the clock and he
has to decide what to do he played
Knight captures on h4 rook captures and
g2 does seem to be the way to go for
example after Knight captures an f5 e
captures now rook to f7 preparing to
pick off the f5 point you need to put
your room behind the passed pawn now f3
rook captures an f5 and now rook the f2
guarding the pawn preparing rook f1 to
push up on all the way to f2 but now
Wesley has King b3 rook f1 King the c4
f2 and now the very important King D 3
so now Ruby one check can be met with
King to e2 and now both the king and the
rook guard the queening square however
you get rugby 1 and then you go after
these guys and well it's maybe maybe
playable but after Knight to d6 Magnus
point for Knight captures on h4 and now
it's a bit different Wesley goes for
rugby 7 check with King day 8 and now
look the b6 going after the pawn here
and you cannot defend it if King defense
then you again just put b5 it's not a
problem threatening rogue character so
after captures captures with check King
just moves now you pick up this pawn and
it will be very very easy game for white
you just move the move the knight get
the King over that to b6 and start well
you could even create some sort of a
mating that if you can get for example
the king to a six and for example you
get tonight the night here and night the
c7 made black we'll have to be very
careful so after this rook to b6
magnitude decides for a nightcap person
G to his best chance now is the past F
pawn and now we have rook captures on a
sex with check King to b8 and look the
b6 with check King back to a8 and now
look the a6 Wesley repeats a couple of
times King to be eight and now we have
looked a b6 with check King to a eight
and now not repeating for the last time
but rather night b5 and now comes nights
the e3
preparing to bring the night summer to
help out with the defense but now Luke
a6 check King Tubby 8 and now comes Luke
back to basics check repeating a few
times King day 8 and now night the c7
check King the a7 and only now rook
captures on e6 so grabbing this pawn
Magnus continues pushing his past pawn
and now rook to f6 putting the rogue
behind the past pawn of course Knights
the g4 now offering a trade of pawns
there's no other way to do it as you
don't have a ways of continuing to
pushing your passport and now instead of
capturing first Wesley pushes the King
further back Knight b5 check King to b8
and only now rook captures on f3 Trading
the points Knight captures on e5 and now
rook the f5 by Wesley look the g5
offering a trade of Brooks and here
Wesley doesn't want to trade he doesn't
want to get a Magnus to start pushing
his passport as well so just rook f8
check King to b7 and now Knight to d6
check with King to c6 and now a
wonderful move by Wesley night to f7
forces a trade of knights and then of
course the rook and pawn and game is
winning for Wesley
there is no looked at 5 because my well
if rook if I just Knight captures here
with check and the again you you were
able to trade nights so it doesn't
change anything Magnus play Knight
captures on f7 and he played it with
such disgust that he threw the night at
Wesley tonight he didn't he didn't just
capture you know like like you would
normally capture a piece but he like
almost threw it at
at df7 square and then I just wiggled
around a bit it was a very very
emotional moment
so night captures an f7 rope captures
and now h5 magnet starts pushing his
past pawn but Wesley continues to do the
same b5 with check and this is just I
mean this is just over of course you
cannot capture the pawn if you capture
the pondan just rook f6 check you have
to keep defending the rook and then just
look a five check you move the King and
then you just pick off the rook so here
you would be losing as you're down a
rookie so here after we five cherrick
Magnus played King D five but at the
moment he played king e5 he also
resigned the game so game 3 goes to
Wesley and as we already mentioned three
points for a win in the classical
section of the match so Wesley is
already up six points in the match so
Magnus will get his chance in Game four
of the classical not lower his Wes is
lead that only three points but it's
gonna be very hard as Wesley out of all
the time formats I believe Wesley is
considered the strongest in in rapid and
then Magnus is considered a favorite in
in the blade section but then again we
might not reach the blade section and
again who's who's to say that Wesley
will not hold his own in blitz so I also
wanted to mention what I meant by
Pandora's Box in the title it seems that
well it could seem it doesn't have to
mean anything but Magnus never lost but
never lost a match to anyone ever since
the the candidates playoffs against 1111
are Anyang
but that was over 10 years ago and ever
since the England defeated him in the
singles Cup in the playoffs it's almost
as if Pandora's box was open you know
people saw that Magnus actually bleeds
that he has weaknesses that he he can be
beaten and maybe ding just maybe showed
other players that you don't have to be
afraid of magnets that you can just play
good moves and he can also lose game so
who knows maybe
ding started something yes you know
maybe things started a revolution we'll
just see so excellent game
Wesley beating Magnus twice in a row now
this is game 3 I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank Robert Hughes
basanta the hall tom Gamal the Matt
Edwards and Dimitri Charleston for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my
previous videos serie thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing well with the coverage of the
world fish random championship and
whatever comes our way and also maybe I
forgot to mention but it's just too easy
to win this you can just push a six or
be sex doesn't really matter you push a
six get the king over to be six there
are no we useful checks with the black
rook and then you just queen the a pawn
so it's it's a very simple about yeah
yeah I think I will see you soon and
have an excellent race today